[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sure is beautiful from the horizon on
heaven living disc origin of life you
are arisen from the horizon you have
filled every land with your beauty you
are fine great radiant lofty over and
above every land you raise buying the
lands to the limit of all you have made
you are the Sun you have reached their
limits you bind them for your beloved
son you are distance but your rays are
on earth you are in their sight but your
movements are hidden you rest in the
western horizon and the land is in
darkness in the matter of death sleepers
and chambers heads covered no I can see
its other anything of theirs can be
taken from under their heads they would
not know every lion goes out from its
den every snake bites darkness envelops
the land is in silence their Creator is
resting in his horizon at daybreak
arisen from the horizon shining as the
disc in day you remove the darkness you
grant your rays and the two lands are in
Festival awakened and standing on their
feet you have raised them up their
bodies cleansed clothing on their arms
are an adoration after sunrise the
entire land carries out its tasks a be
heard rests in its pastures trees and
plants are sprouting birds flying up for
their nests their wings and adoration
for your spirit every flock frolics of
fruits all that fly
they live when you have shunned for them
boats sail north and south too
every road is opened at your sunrise and
the fish on the river leap at the side
of you your rays penetrated the great
green you who caused the sperm to grow
in women who turn seed into people who
causes the Sun to live in the womb of
his mother who silences him and stopping
him crying nurse in the womb who gives
breath to cause all he has made to live
when he goes down from the womb to
breathe on the day of his birth you open
his mouth and form you make his needs
when the chicken the egg speaks in the
shell and give it breath within to cause
it to live you have made him he is
complete to break out from the egg and
he emerges from the egg to speak to his
completion and walks on his legs going
out from it how numerous are your works
though hidden from sight unique God
there is none beside him you mold the
earth to your wish you and you alone all
people herds and flocks all on earth
that walk on legs fall on high that fly
with her wings and on the foreign lands
of hard and cush the land of Egypt you
place every man in his place you make
what they need so that everyone has his
food his life span counted tongues are
separated in speech and forms to their
skins are made different for you make
foreign lands different you make a flood
in the underworld and bring it at your
desire to cost the populace to live as
you made them for you Lord of all day
labor over the Lord of every land shine
for them o discs of day grain of dignity
all distant lands you make them live you
place a flood in the sky to descend for
them you make waves over the mountains
like the great green to water their
fields with their settlements how
effective they are your plants Oh Lord
of eternity a flood in the sky for
foreigners for the flux of every land
that go on foot and a flood to come from
the underworld for Egypt your race
nursing every medal you shine and they
live and grow for you you make the
seasons to nurture all you may winter to
cool them heat so they may taste you you
have made the forest sky to shine in it
to see what you make while you are far
and shining in your form as a living
disc risen shining distant near you make
millions of forms from yourself lone one
cities towns fields the road of rivers
every eye sees you in their entry you
are the disc of day master of your move
of the existence of every form you
create alone what you have made
you are in my hearts there is none other
who knows you beside your son never kept
Aurora soul one of the raw you instruct
him in your plans in your strength the
land comes into being by your action as
you make them and when you have shown
they live when you rest they die you are
a lifetime in your body people live by
you eyes are on your beauty until you
set all work is stopped when you set on
the west shine and strength and all for
the king
motion is in every leg since you founded
the earth you raised them for your son
who come from your body
the king who lives on right Lord of the
two lands never kept arruda a soul one
of raw son of raw who lives on right
Lord of risings Akhenaten great in his
lifespan and the great Kings wife whom
he loves lady of the two lands never
never rot and Nefertiti eternally alive
[Music]
you